i am a sun sneezer which is also known
as having the photic sneeze reflex
or the autosomal dominant compelling
heliophthalmic outburst syndrome
which basically means if i go from a
dark area into somewhere that's brightly
lit
you know like looking at the sun i will
sneeze
wait for it
there you go i'm a sun sneezer
but why does this happen
people have known about this effect for
at least a few thousand years
aristotle was probably a sun sneezer
because in his
book of problems he asked why does the
sun
provoke sneezing and his answer was it
was the heat from the sun
which causes sweating inside your nose
and so you sneeze to get rid of the
moisture
but a couple millennia later sir francis
bacon demonstrated that this could not
be the case because when he
closed his eyes and turned towards the
sun well he did not experience that
photic sneeze reflect so
his explanation was that it was the eyes
watering and then
when some of that moisture got down into
the nose that caused the tickle which
makes you sneeze
but even this theory has its problems
because eye watering is much slower
process than the photic sneeze reflects
so it can't be the cause before i
started researching sun sneezing
i thought that having the photic sneeze
reflex must convey some sort of
evolutionary advantage onto the people
who have it
if you think about it sneezing is a way
of transmitting disease
in your snot there can be the living
bacteria that cause
tuberculosis and strep throat or viruses
that cause measles mumps rubella and
influenza
so if you're living in a moist dark cave
and you sneeze
or your snot lands on the floor or the
walls of the cave and
those pathogens can stay alive for hours
or even days
increasing the likelihood of spreading
that disease to other people who live
with you in your cave
whereas if you only sneeze when you
emerge from the darkness of the cave
and into bright sunlight well then that
mucus
will quickly dry out or because it's
exposed to the harmful uv rays of the
sun
it will kill all of those pathogens
greatly decreasing
the risk of spread of disease
by the 1960s some studies were revealing
the hereditary nature of the photic
sneeze reflex
there was a father who would sneeze two
times when he entered bright sunlight
and when they tested his baby daughter
who was just four weeks old
moving her from a dark room into full
sunlight also caused her to sneeze
exactly two times and by the 1980s it
was clear that this trait was
autosomal dominant meaning that you only
needed to
inherit one copy of the gene from just
one of your parents
in order to exhibit the trait but when
studies the population have been done
only about 18 to 35 percent of people
actually have the photic sneeze reflex
so
i don't really think this gives a great
evolutionary
advantage otherwise everyone would have
it
you know it could just be one of those
random mutations that happens over time
and
sustains itself because it's neither
good nor bad evolutionarily speaking
so it affects roughly one in four people
can you spot the person with the photic
sneeze reflex
nowadays it's actually been found that
the gene responsible for the photic
sneeze reflex
is on the second chromosome and it's a
single letter of dna that's been changed
on my second chromosome i have a c where
non-sun sneezers have a t and the reason
that we know this is that back in 2010
there was a study of about 10 000 people
where they went online and they
reported whether they were sun sneezers
or not and then their dna was analyzed
and the
groups were compared and what they found
was the thing that sun sneezers had in
common
was this one particular letter change in
their dna
that i think is pretty amazing
now it's unclear exactly how this change
affects your physiology and makes you
more susceptible to sun sneezes
but the best theory at the moment is
that it involves the trigeminal nerve
which is
the largest cranial nerve it involves
all of the feeling that you have in your
face
and as the name implies it actually has
three branches
one of which receives stimuli from your
eye and another which receives stimuli
from your nose
so the thought is that this really
active stimulation of the optic nerve
may cross over into the maxillary branch
causing that little tickle which gets
you to sneeze
photic sneezes are generally pretty
harmless unless you're doing something
like flying a fighter jet or performing
some sort of delicate
surgery but this methodology can allow
us to learn a lot about different
heritable traits and diseases
just by studying lots of people and
their genotypes
this episode of veritasium was supported
by 23andme which is actually the company
that figured out that gene polymorphism
uh responsible for the photic
sneeze reflex the name of the company
23andme comes from the fact that humans
actually have 23
pairs of chromosomes and the purpose of
the company is to give people insight
into their own dna
so what you do is spit into a vial which
is
actually much harder than it sounds and
send it off to them
and of course in your saliva are some of
the cells from your mouth they analyze
the dna from those cells
and then they send you a report where
you can find out tons of stuff about
your genes
like where do your genes come from that
is what's your ancestry and
do you have the photic sneeze reflex do
we share the same
uh change of dna on our second
chromosome
you can also learn about your health and
other physical traits
and how much neanderthal you are so if
you want to learn more about your
genotype
then you should go to 23andme.com
veritasium
so i want to thank 23andme for
supporting me and i want to thank you
for watching